[Music]
today morning rounds we explore a new
movement of Americans who are reducing
their consumption of alcohol or cutting
it out entirely in life and online
interest in this community is booming on
Instagram more than 1.2 million posts
carry the hashtag sober life more than
500,000 boast sober is sexy dr. Tara
Narula is here with why more Americans
are turning to this movement Tara who's
taking part well good morning Anthony
this demographic is wide-ranging and
all-encompassing while you may have
heard about dry January or sober
September this is year-round some of
these people are recovering from alcohol
addiction but for a large part many are
abstaining from alcohol in pursuit of a
healthier cleaner lifestyle
it's called mindful drinking or sober
curious and it's reshaping what a night
out looks like really hard to be like in
your early 20s and you know doing things
that doesn't revolve around drinking 23
year old Michaela Barry is one of the
hundreds of thousands of Americans who
identify as sober curious drinking less
or not at all I really like going out
and meeting people and it's you know a
little bit harder to do and everyone is
like connections not as genuine there's
this kind of blind spot in culture where
a lot of our social life and a lot of
our nightlife is exclusively built
around alcohol
that's why Lorelei been Droste created
listen bar in New York a pop up booze
free bar and social space for
clear-headed connections do you see this
as a niche market or something that
potentially is going to grow and take
off I'm seeing all of this like big
business indicators of how the category
is growing if you like this big brands
like Budweiser you'll like this too but
in Heineken doing now sells zero alcohol
beers the non-alcoholic beer industry is
expected to grow to over 25 billion
dollars by 2024 and there's also a slew
of alcohol free spirits saturating the
market
now it comes from a place of people
being very considerate with their
choices the movement is also helping
those in recovery it comes down to
connection and engagement
MJ Gottlieb created the app lucid to
connect recovering addicts and the sober
curious when I was getting sober
it was diners and coffee shops right
that was it now to be able to show
Topher dating sober vents sober travel
sober groups and let the sober
individuals connect on the Lucid
platform that's the magical part you
know we grow up hearing you know alcohol
is bad and what they don't tell us is
the first time we have a drink is it
actually feels good
we met lucid user Philip O'Hara at
getaway in Brooklyn
one of the first brick-and-mortar sober
bars in the country I remember like
being at a bar 23 years old feeling
completely not okay until I had a drink
O'Hara has been in recovery for over
three years and says an app like this
provides a space to socialize safely you
have a platform for people to be
connected with other sober people and
then the sober curious movement gets
brought into it right turns out you like
going to the silver bar you have more
fun you make more connections and then
you decide on your own that like I
actually have more fun without alcohol
think like we like to avoid the way that
we're actually feeling or kind of not
confront things that are right in front
of us and I think that's what I was
using alcohol for and I think that
that's how it was has been used in my
family's history a new study found
abstaining from alcohol could actually
boost mental health and well-being do
you think that something like this sober
curious sober revolution sober bars is
going to help us when it comes to our
mental health I mean in my experience
like in my generation I think really
prioritizing their mental health and we
talked a lot about self-care now I think
it's a huge part of what's driving this
you know silver curious movement is is
the amount of mental health and
depression issues that people are
realizing they can't solve what
substances and so with the holidays
right around the corner you may be
seeing more family members or friends
around that dinner table choosing to
skip that glass of wine or cocktail and
for those of you that do choose to drink
the see
DC Dietary Guidelines for alcohol
consumption is one drink a day for women
and two a day for men so interesting yes
I mean I think it's really important
people have an option a lot of people
joked about this idea of being out and
actually having a meaningful connection
remembering the name of the person that
they interacted with or what they talked
about and and that's very important
that's what the bar tab comes to and
it's a lot smaller yes like the idea of
it but I know people that drink really
like that too and anything in moderation
we'll be right back